we do have hope one man stands out Above
the Rest and that man is Tucker Carlson
Joe Rogan says Tucker Carlson could win
the presidency in 2028 if the fired Fox
News house decides to run he has no
nonsense
why doesn't Joe have Tucker on his show
that would be that would be the biggest
I think I think it'd be the biggest
episode he's ever done
as right as of right now it would be the
biggest podcast probably ever done
does Rogan have to go on Tucker show
actually hold on simulcast it yeah
I think if right now Joe and Tucker did
an episode it would be potentially the
biggest podcast ever done
but if Joe and Trump do a podcast it's
the biggest the biggest ever done it's
the most beautiful on top of that
Joe Trump and uh and Tucker Carlson on
the uh let's go on the culture oh right
over there yeah all right but if you got
if you got Rogan Carlson and Trump in
one room for one like two or three hour
conversation be amazing it would
everyone in the world would be would be
listening in do that at Mar-A-Lago jeez
I would absolutely love that dude
awesome I don't think that Tucker has
any uh I don't think he's gonna run no
yeah why would you want to if you're him
like you get to do whatever you want
right now from Maine as far as I'm
concerned like you live your life you
get to have fun guests on you have
enormous influence but you don't have
the restrictions that the president does
or the responsibilities and if you think
Tucker's not paying attention to the
fact that you know they're trying to put
Trump in prison you know like he's a
father do you think that that he's going
to risk jail time to tell the truth to
the American people I don't think so and
I don't think that I think someone like
Tucker someone that is that much of an
outsider or at least treats The
Establishment and the specifically the
security uh and intelligence apparatus
that the government built
um that treats it with such disdain and
and speaks so frankly about it I think
that he would be a Target right away and
he would be targeted by the by the that
apparatus in a similar fashion to the
way that Trump was the big issue though
is
how much power Tucker would have to give
up to be president right he wouldn't
become more influential he wouldn't gain
more he would be less yeah it'd be a
different Power though I think like
theoretically if if the figurehead
position of President actually has any
true power he would be able to remedy
some of the things that he's pointed out
with his journalism Trump shows that it
does
okay well I think for the most part they
expect presidents to be figureheads who
fall in line and just March in lockstep
you're allowed to affect domestic policy
negotiate amongst your party and but
don't screw with our plans
the fact that they are so desperately
trying to destroy Trump shows when
you're the president you have the power
yeah you can do that they may defy you
lie cheat and steal keep our troops
overseas but Donald Trump can go on
television and say I is the president
hereby order it be done and now they're
in trouble do you guys buy this Q Anon
thing that's happening what over the
past 48 hours there was this lady that
uh that puts out this video where she's
talking about how like I can't even
break it down it's so nutty sounding to
me but Trump then truth it whatever that
means and then like General whatever his
name is the guy that got thrown in jail
and then got released yeah Flynn now the
cue stuff is is nonsense but Trump is
pumping it though dude like it's he's
going hard on it I've never seen
anything like that it's terrible but
what are you even talking about yeah
what does she say it's just it's a it's
like a five minute video she says a
bunch of Bonkers stuff I don't know if
any of it's legitimate guys I just can't
introduce
explain it I can't explain it it's it
sounds
too crazy
when you get home they say all right
they said that it was like the the
United States is a corporation that's
bankrupt and Joe Biden's the president
of this bankrupt Corporation but he
Trump is still the actual president
yeah dude see this is what I'm talking
about when did when do you post this I
think it was yesterday I think no a
couple days ago I don't know it wasn't
that long ago I'm looking at his truth
right now I'm going back I don't see
anything what am I missing what am I
supposed to be looking for there's this
older lady that was on the news in on
Fox and you're no in Europe
I don't know I I bro I was three days
ago well he re-truthed these maybe he
deleted it I don't know truth well these
are re-truths he's retreating old
memories again he should have made it
Trump a trumpet and then he'd be
returning trumpet you don't understand
okay here's one day ago he says rigged
election blah blah blah
no look I'll just tell you that that the
US is a corporation stuff is it sounds
like nonsense to me but I don't know it
is nonsense that Rhonda said this is
getting roasted consistently no matter
what he does or says but he made a
really good point that I completely
agree with on the 2020 election he said
whoever puts their hand in the Bible on
the on January 20th one
I've been saying something very similar
Trump lost and they're like no you
didn't know that I'm like yes he did
because if he won he'd be standing up
there winning this you know it wouldn't
really really Grands my gears is that
people think this is the one time the
one time there was malfeasance in an
election or something like ridiculous as
if the entirety of Elections have always
been some dirty underhanded scheme to
find loopholes to gain power always
perhaps the shadow campaign as described
by Time Magazine is the worst we've seen
it right Fair Point
but yo
there's there's powerful Global uh
interests businesses big businesses
light bulb manufacturers you know
they're they're they're they're they're
trying to make LED lights I'm half
kidding they are but uh uh they're a
powerful powerful people in this country
who want to win to set law and policy
and they will do whatever they can to
get it
that means this idea that election day
is some holiday where we all smile walk
down to the voting booth wave and then
shake hands and say I'm gonna cast my
vote for this person best of luck to
your candidate sir and then when the
news comes in saying well unfortunately
your candidate was shy by five votes
they go oh well gee golly I'll try
harder next time it's never been the
case people have always been doing Shady
stuff there's always been lies and
manipulation and they will do whatever
so that on the 20th they can stand
before this country and say they won
winning is not about this this hokey
vision of people casting a ballot well
it's War I think yeah well that's that's
the thing that's changed though in my
lifetime is that now when you lose a
federal election you feel like there's a
chance that you and your loved ones
might go to prison you know like and I'm
not even like being really hyperbolic
because had Trump won the January 6th
stuff probably you know even if it were
to have transpired it wouldn't have
ended up with people serving massive
massive time
um but that's really where we're at now
is like where depending on which side
win the other side feels as if they are
jeopardized and in the next existential
fashion and that's disturbing I think
maybe I found the video that you're
talking about this one from GB views
that's the one and what is it she like
will it play it's it's long dude don't
don't even it's it's long don't go there
and honestly it's 10 minutes long
there's no way we're gonna be able to
break that down
and it's like a screen grab of a Turk
someone from turkeys watching British
news but Trump puts it out
like he retrothed it or whatever so I
and he's like he's like this is
brilliant this woman and I'm like this
sounds this sounds like the the people
with the blonde hair no no no it's an
older lady that we're interviewing
someone just tweeted it at me okay I'm
I'm gonna walk definitely gonna watch it
later yeah it's gonna give you a full
review tomorrow we have the Super Chat
from Nick long he said Q is real look up
x22 report for actual information on cue
the info y'all have is half truths why
does the media attack you so much think
about it I'll tell you why
um look the media is a lot of liars a
lot of activists and we still use a lot
of these sources we just have to fact
check them
yeah I'll tell you I'll tell you my
views on this stuff first a lot of it is
you know when this stuff first started
coming out and people were tweeting
about Q I was like I don't know you know
I'll take a look at what this is and
then sure enough there's a lot of
garbled gibberish nonsense right and
there were a lot of like Nostradamus
style statements where it was like the
Raven has Has Lifted the suitcase has
been deposited Saturday comes and people
people would start taking these posts
and then dissecting what they could mean
with news reports and I'm like okay
y'all lost it lyrics then I actually met
some people and I had a guy asking me if
I would report on Trump becoming
president on March 7th or whatever the
date was and I was like my friend that's
not going to happen right and he was
like no man you got to be the real news
like this is true you got to look it up
and I was like I did it's not true right
and then sure enough Trump did not
become president well see that that's
the thing that that rubs me the wrong
way about it my aunt did the same thing
to me she's like she's like Clint you
have a political podcast you got to talk
about this stuff I was like I was like I
think it's all nonsense I'm sorry Auntie
but it's just the history of it is not
good I had someone come to me after the
election 2020 and they said why aren't
you reporting on the fact that Trump did
win and that he's still the president
and that he's gonna be brought in in
March and Biden is not really the Victor
and I was like what are you talking
about what makes you believe this and he
was like you're gonna look so dumb when
Trump is inaugurated on March and I was
like honestly rated in March I said if
it's if it's true that Trump that does
happen I didn't say anything about it so
I won't look one way or the other if I
come out right now and do a whole
segment about how it's not going to
happen sure maybe but I'm not even
talking about it at all because it's
nonsense right but but here's what
happened they said in March first it was
like it'll be the real inaugural
inauguration will be January then
February then March then they talk about
how it used to be that inauguration was
in March but after the Civil War it
changed and they shifted it back and
there's a reason for that you can read
the history it's about them trying to
stop short and lame duck sessions or
something like this then they were like
after March they were like well that's
because it's actually going to be in
June and I'm like oh and then June came
around nothing happened and they're like
exactly yeah but it's because my
favorite Conspiracy Theory with the Q
stuff
was that Joe Biden was actually already
arrested and that he was secretly
pretending to be president to Shield
Donald Trump because we were at war with
Russia
that's wild but that's why as opposed to
being a doomsday cult where you
constantly uh extend the calendar window
by which your prediction has to come
true they are a hopium cult where like
the the the deadline by which the good
thing that's supposed to happen that
will never happen is gets extended 60
days every time it drives me nuts but
anyways Trump actually was like fully
acknowledging these insane ramblings of
this case and I was like I was like or
this is the reason I I brought it up to
Tim actually is because if all right so
here's the two options Trump is either a
a you know he's actually in on this Q
thing and it's real which I don't
believe at all or
he's lying to his supporters and and
leading them on with this nonsense which
is not a good thing or he's actually
duped by it
which is maybe the worst possible
outcome so like is there a good option
as to why Trump's doing this I know okay
so it's either blue it on or it's you
know 4chan just playing a fun game and I
don't I can't tell you what it is
why I say blue and on so well blue and
on is Democrats oh yeah blowing on is
like Democrats who believe in Russia
gate and all that nonsense and they're
like ah it's the same thing right and
it's it's
it's it it breaks my heart a little bit
that these people refuse to actually
recognize the world in front of them
thus the Deep State wins well that's why
I've always assumed that Q Anon was a
psychological operation because it
completely defend people during this
time where you would have expected them
to be absolutely out of their minds
Furious and they're like no no no
at the time when you needed activists to
be filing lawsuits to be showing up with
signs in front of courthouses making
demands for regisive grievances exactly
they actually all just stayed at the
computers and were like whoa exactly
I'll just sit here because it's all part
of the guy trust the plan
trust the plan as it all gets Swept Away
not Donald Trump's facing
641 years in prison it's all part of the
plan well trust the plan everybody they
did say where we go one week we go all
so now they're all going to prison it's
uh I didn't think they I don't think
they thought it was going in that
direction though it's really it's crazy
man yeah Trump's now facing 641 years in
prison because all these people trusted
the plan it's unreal crazy seems like
not a great plan is being indicted it's
part of the plan
yeah the Democrats plan dude the whole
plan was from the Democrats
that's why I keep saying blue and on
because it's just that's what it is I
mean come on it's nice though because
now whenever you don't want to explain
your decision to someone you say trust
the plan and they have to
yeah trust the plan the Deep State
whispered to president Trump you cannot
withstand the storm the president
whispered whispered back I am the storm
I'm imagining Trump in an orange
jumpsuit in a prison somewhere
Whispering like I'm the storm
I know you've got a lot of Hope for him
in his second term but theoretically if
he were to actually get through it and
it's actually a legitimate election all
blah blah but like if he's actually
buying this nonsense what what does that
pretend for the conservatives moving
forward there's there's no such thing as
a quote-unquote legitimate election this
is what I always try to tell people
because they're like oh this wasn't fair
and you know whatever and I'm like dude
every election they do something to gain
an edge there it there there is no world
in which we all right here today say
hello everyone I would like to vote on
what we order for dinner I propose Pizza
how do you vote sir
pizza two okay we have two votes for
pizza and then we all sit down and we
count the ballots and we go wow Pizza
wins then we all high five that that's
never never happened
quite literally it's like hey everybody
I'm voting on whether or not we're gonna
have pizza and um I have these military
votes there's ten of them for pizza uh
your votes don't matter right there's
always been some weird nonsense thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time